[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée à la présidentielle en côte
d'ivoire nous sommes avec jean louis
billon secrétaire exécutif de la
communication du pdci- rda le parti
démocratique de côte d'ivoire
rassemblement démocratique africain il
s'agit du parti de l'ex président henri
konan-bédié qui est candidat pour le
scrutin du 31 octobre bonjour jean louis
billon merci d'avoir accepté de
participer à cette grande interview
merci pourquoi ce n'est pas vous le
candidat du pdc yves jean louis billon
vous disposez pourtant d'un sacré cv
ancien ministre du commerce et de
l'artisanat de la promotion des pme d'un
gouvernement d'alassane ouattara
président ancien président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de côte
d'ivoire la liste elle est très longue
pourquoi ce n'est pas vous le candidat
du pdci parce que c' est le choix de
consensus que nous avons fait au niveau
du parti et j'ai décidé moi de retirer
ma candidature au profit de celle en les
collant bédié à partir du moment où ils
avaient d'essayer d'être candidat vous
voyez nous avons connu des troubles
importante dans notre partie dû à la
volonté de fusion absorption du rhdp qui
voulait faire disparaître le pdci il
était important à ce moment là que nous
fassions une union sacrée autour du
président henri konon bédié pour
préserver les intérêts du parti
sauvegarder notre parti et le présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
pour continuer avec ce même parti nous
sommes tous ensemble et il passera là
mais notre nouvelle génération alors on
rit konan-bédié il a 86 ans il a dirigé
le pays de 1993 à 1999 avant d'être
renversé par robert gay c'est un élément
d'ailleurs qui a été déclencheur dans la
crise ivoirienne qui a paralysé la côte
d'ivoire dans les années 2000 est ce que
vous croyez qu'avec cette candidature du
pdc y votre parti reste crédible dans
votre pays mais aussi aux yeux du monde
entier en vue de l'élection du 31
octobre
complètement oui à partir du moment où
le président henri konan bédié revient
dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie
et retrouver la cohésion sociale que
nous avons perdu malheureusement lorsque
le présent répondants bédié avait signé
l'accord politique qui crée le rhdp
il y avait dans sa volonté la cohésion
sociale à rétablir en côte d'ivoire et
la paix à restaurer malheureusement
quelques années après on se rend compte
que ce choix qu'elle était porteur
abandonné a fini par s'effriter par une
volonté hégémonique du rhdp et nous
repartons malheureusement vers une crise
debout devant réparer beaucoup de choses
et bien sûr le plaisir économie dié et
crédible en ce sens c'est vrai que vous
fustigez le président alassane ouattara
est candidat à sa propre succession en
lice pour un troisième mandat après le
décès du premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly et évidemment le débat
constitutionnel qui pose question le
cumul des mandats le renouvellement de
la classe politique aussi est-ce que sur
ce dernier point
votre parti donne l'exemple en matière
de renouvellement de la classe politique
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui est
constituée autour j'ai présent dans les
compétitions de jeunes dans le cadre
et c'est cette équipe là qu'il a dirigé
le pays aux côtés du prison économie
dieu elle est nettement plus jeunes
d'ailleurs que celle qui constitue c'est
au tour du pays 02
c'est difficile quand même de croire
aujourd'hui qu'à un renouvellement au
sein de votre parti au difficile parce
que vous regardez l'âge du candidat mais
je vous répète que l'équipe intégral est
quand même une équipe ce crime en jeu le
climat politique il est très tendue avec
de la contestation des violences des
victimes les manifestations au moment où
on réalise cet entretien en tout cas
sont interdites jusqu'au 15 septembre
est ce que ces tensions d'une part elle
vous inquiète comment vous analysez ces
tensions et où elles peuvent amener le
pays selon vous forcément nous inquiète
parce que il y à violence il ya mort
d'homme destruction de biens et cela
n'augure rien de bon pour la suite
mais voyez vous c'était prévisible
chaque fois qu'il est question d'un
troisième mandat dans nos pays d'afrique
il y à des violences lorsque l'on décide
de faire un troisième mandat on instaure
un climat d'insécurité et pose les
ingrédients pour une future stabilité
nous sommes aujourd'hui en crise
préélectorale nous allons certainement
vers une crise électorale suivie d'une
crise post électorale
si les choses devaient rester en l'état
sur la candidature même du président
alassane ouattara qu'est ce qui vous
gêne le plus d'abord chaque fois qu'il
est question de troisième mandat c'est
pas très bon nous devons accepter la
limitation des mandats à deux
c'est l'esprit de la loi obtient du
moment où cet esprit est faussée en
disant je peux faire un troisième mandat
parce que les compteurs sont remis à
zéro
c'est la même rengaine que l'on entend
dans tous les pays africains qui triture
les constitutions on va rester là vitam
aeternam
heureusement que l'être humain n'est pas
éternel sinon dans cent ans on aura un
président qui serait là en train de vous
dire je commence la 56e le premier
mandat de la 56e république s'est pas
séparé c'est pas crédible baryton toutes
les grandes démocraties tous les pays
les plus avancés connaissent une
limitation de mandat et il est grand
temps que sur le continent africain en
afrique francophone en particulier nous
connaissions nous aussi les limitations
de monde
vous avez demandé le report des scrutins
du
du 31 octobre parce que c'est toujours
le cas et si oui pour quelles raisons
n'ont pas demandé le report du scrutin
je mettais un avis lors d'une discussion
en disant que vous remplir les
conditions si nous devons désormais
totalement la commission électorale
indépendante
auditer la liste électorale et que cela
nécessitait dans leurs ports moi
personnellement je mourrai pas
d'inconvénient mais c'est une opinion
personnelle
aujourd'hui nous demandons toujours
l'audit de la liste électorale la
réforme de la commission électorale
indépendante avec la bonne volonté de
pouvoir le faire lors des temps mais bon
cette bonne volonté n'existe pas pour
l'instant
certaines commissions électorales qui
est contesté
pour que lui reprocher son manque
d'indépendance
vous voyez vous elle a été choisie de
façon unilatérale les personnes qui la
composent sont des membres de partis
connue essentiellement le parti
présidentiel le président de la
commission et lui-même ancien directeur
de cabinet du président du conseil
constitutionnel actuel
ancien ministre et du conseil national
et ancien ministre du gouvernement et
allié du président ouattara
donc tout ça n'augure rien de bon pour
la suite
une commission électorale a n'est pas
l'endroit de crédit peut-être autonome
doit être indépendante
alex tanguay ne l'est nullement votre
candidat henri konan bédié a été très
clair pas de troisième mandat pour
alassane ouattara il a été ferme sur ce
point jusqu'où le pdci est il prêt à
aller pour faire barrage à alassane
ouattara alors oui vous j'espère que le
conseil constitutionnel va dire le droit
il dira le droit serait de refuser notre
troisième mandat au président alassane
ouattara
malheureusement comme je le voulais et
angie se penser et constitutionnel nous
ne sommes pas sûrs que lui-même et
l'indépendance suffisante
odier le droit véritablement auparavant
il a dit le droit
dans des situations similaires en disant
que les textes réglementaires existants
par le passé n'ayant pas changé dans la
nouvelle institution
il n'y a pas de rétroactivité ou pour
changer le texte alors nous attendons
nous espérons que ce conseil
constutionnel sauve à sauvegarder la
côte d'ivoire d'une crise inévitable
alors vous souvenez quand 2010 à
l'époque le pdci faisait partie de cette
alliance houphouétiste soutenaient
alassane ouattara la porte et même au
pouvoir vous souhaitez qu'en 2010 la
cour constitutionnelle s'est prononcée
et finalement votre camp est allé à
l'encontre de sa décision
oui le en 2000 en 2010 mais dont nous
attendent en 2020 chaque fois nos beaux
yeux concédé constitution qui a été
lui-même acteurs de la crise et nous
espérons que ce dernier conseil
constitutionnel saura se met au dessus
des choix partisans et sera un acteur de
réconciliation nationale l'acteur de
collection l'acteur de paix il est grand
temps que nous conseil constutionnel
sache prendre leur indépendance
les autorités évoquent des actes
insurrectionnels passible de poursuites
judiciaires est ce que c'est la réalité
on peut réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire la
liberté d'expression n'est nullement
insurrectionnelle voyez vous si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de climat
insurrectionnel les ivoiriens ont marché
à paris à new york
ces marchands étaient encadrés libre il
n'y a eu aucune violence
pourquoi sommes nous différents à
l'étranger et en côte d'ivoire ce sont
les mêmes ivoiriens ce que nous
réclamons c'est la liberté la liberté
d'expression la liberté
pinon la liberté de réunion la liberté
de manifester ce que somme toute notre
constitution nous accorde cette liberté
d'expression de manifester aujourd'hui
les autorités vous l'interdisent partir
du moment où les marges sont réprimées
alors que nous demandons expressément
par écrit l'autorisation de marcher que
ça nous est refusé oui nous sommes
complètement
qu'est ce qui se passe concrètement à
daoukro le fief de votre parti de votre
leader henri konan-bédié ya des
manifestations qui vire au conflit
communautaire entre les baoulé l'ethnie
de votre leader et lé malaquin si cela
aujourd'hui la côte d'ivoire où vous
réfutez justement c'est ce ces conflits
communautaires il il ya eu
malheureusement des conflits
communautaires pas seulement comme égal
mois au doigt divo gagnoa dans diverses
régions de la côte d'ivoire et cela
malheureusement est essentiellement due
à cette volonté de troisième mandat qui
se traduit pour une bonne partie des
ivoiriens par une confiscation du
pouvoir
s'il n'y a pas de volonté de faire un
troisième mandat il n'y aura pas de
violences
c'est chaque fois qu'il ya ce sentiment
d'injustice que la violence et
l'instabilité revenait non il faut voir
l'origine de la violence est l'origine
de la violence c'est le non respect de
la constitution
mais des cas d un conflit communautaire
même il y a eu des événements qui sont
traduits en conseil communautaire dans
diverses régions aujourd'hui le calme et
relativement revenus mais nous craignons
que cela puisse
renaître si jamais il n'y a pas une
volonté d'apaisement de part et d'autre
est essentiellement de la part du
pouvoir en place qui malheureusement a
orienté les violences en actionnant des
forces de l'ordre elles-mêmes aux côtés
de certaines castle jean louis billon va
marquer à une courte pause et on va
poursuivre cet entretien avec vous on se
retrouve dans un instant à tout de suite
[Musique]
un retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec jean louis billon le
secrétariat exécutif de la communication
du pdci rda le parti de l'ex président
henri konan bédié candidat à la
présidentielle du 31 octobre jean louis
billon
on parlait du climat de tension actuelle
en côte d'ivoire vous dites vous que les
autorités instrumentalise certaines
manifestations certaine violence
oui à partir du moment où lorsque le
parti au pouvoir manifestent lui le
droit de manifester ses partisans à
manifester
et quand l'opposition manifeste la
police la gendarmerie tout le monde et
d'un homme pour barrer
cette opposition est d' empêcher de
manifester et l etat passé et les
emprisonner cela crée forcément le
climat de violence et les des casseurs
sont encadrés par certaines forces de
l'ordre
est ce l'avis d'admission ce sont vos
militants qui manifestent dans la rue
oui ce sont nos militants et pas
seulement nos militants nos
sympathisants et tous les ivoiriens
épris de justice de démocratie et de
liberté d'expression
alors en 2010 vous avez les mouvements
sont dans beaucoup d'endroits ont été
spontanées en 2010 vous avez avec le pdc
y porter alassane ouattara donc au
pouvoir on disait tout à l'heure
pourquoi il ya eu des 10
dion au sein du rhdp pourquoi cette
rupture avec le pdc votre parti tout
simplement parce que un moment donné le
rhdp ou plus haut pour parler vrai le
rdr a voulu créer un parti unique avec
le rhdp est absorbée esteli et tous les
autres partis qui étaient signataires de
l'accord politique
il composait le rhdp en demandant à ses
autres partis puisque la loi est claire
là dessus on ne peut pas exister un
parti un peu ne peut pas exister en deux
parties en deux fois
donc il fallait tout simplement liquider
le pdci rda
ce qui était inconcevable pour les
militants du pdci pour moi comme pour
tous nous sommes opposés à cette fusion
absorption et nous avons décidé de
sortir de l'accord politique est de ne
pas intégrer ce nouveau parti unifié
créé par le rd il faut savoir au passage
que le rdr a officiellement disparu
puisque il est aujourd'hui au sein du
rhdp et le rhdp au final se retrouve
tout seul donc c'est de rdr a simplement
fait que changer de carapace lagardère
cas elle appartient à l'initial
d'alassane ouattara sur le bilan
économique de l'actuel président après
deux mandats auxquels d'ailleurs le pdci
on le rappelle a collaboré avant le la
pandémie le fmi a placé la côte d'ivoire
dans le pôle peloton de tête des pays
les plus dynamiques d'afrique même au
monde avec l'ethiopie et le rwanda sur
ce bilan
quel est justement quels sont vos
observations
le bilan c'est c'est une responsabilité
collective que nous avons sur ce bilan
vous voyez la côte d'ivoire depuis 2000
était en crise
jusqu'en 2010 le processus de
développement et est complètement
arrêtée lorsque nous avons retrouvé la
paix en 2011 la croissance a été
automatique
il est vrai que de nombreuses politiques
ont été salutaires pour faire repartir
l'économie
mais le processus développement ayant
repris il était normal de connaître
cette croissance
donc oui nous avons connu une croissance
et il faut saluer cela malheureusement
il faut atténuer aussi les chiffres de
la croissance parce que le niveau de
pauvreté est resté élevé et cette
croissance ne s'est pas traduite par un
partage de richesse plus équitable et
malheureusement la réconciliation
nationale a fait défaut d'ivoire et une
bonne partie de ceux qui étaient nos
opposants hier on était des
laissés-pour-compte de la politique de
la ville dans ses colonies
c'est ce qu'on appelle un peu la justice
des vainqueurs en tout cas ce que les
ivoiriens qualifiés de justice des
vainqueurs sur cette réconciliation
nationale pourquoi vous dénoncez un
échec
tout simplement parce que nous devons
construire une côte d'ivoire pour tous
nous avons une communauté de destin et
aucun égard il doit se sentir exclus du
processus de développement du processus
de construction de sa nation trop
d'ivoiriens sont aujourd'hui exilé trop
d'ivoiriens sont aujourd'hui en dehors
de la côte d'ivoire et ne participent
pas à la vie économique et sociale de
leur nation donc c'est pour ça
oui et nous voulons avoir une paix
durable il faut que tous ceux qui sont
avec sérieux puissent rentrer en toute
liberté et en paix et tous ses partisans
et tous les autres ivoiriens qui ne
veulent pas rentrer en côte d'ivoire
parce qu'ils se disent que c'est un pays
où l'état de droit n'existe voilà
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous sommes engagés
et nous voulons rétablir une côte
d'ivoire qui se traduit par une
communauté d'être égaux en droits mais
aussi des devoirs
lorsque vous dites c'est qu'il faut
faire revenir l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo qui est exilé en belgique il faut
faire revenir aussi charles blé goudé
guillaume soro également c'est ce que
vous dites tous les ignorer aucun
ivoirien ne doit se retrouver à
l'extérieur pour des raisons politiques
et ils sont nombreux il ya aussi la
possible au social la mine ils sont
nombreux les ouailles à l'extérieur ce
n'est pas un discours électoral que vous
tenez vous pensez sincèrement ce que
vous dites
parce que si on peut penser que laurent
gbagbo il dispose d'une large base au
sein du s p é
en tout cas une frange dure du fpi l'est
les pro gbagbo
c'est le cas aussi de charles blé goudé
qui a une vraie assise au niveau de la
jeunesse ivoirienne charles guillaume
soro c'est la même chose vous espérez
peut-être que leurs bases orange à vos
côtés dans le cadre du scrutin
présidentiel n'en voyez vous c'est pas
du tout le discours et toile il est bon
pour que la côte d'ivoire soit en paix
ou que la côte d'ivoire soit stable que
tous les ivoiriens se sentent bien chez
eux
beaucoup d'entre eux sont des
adversaires ou l'outil et ce ne sont pas
des ennemis et bien au contraire
je souhaite qu'ils rendent en côte
d'ivoire et qu'il rentre en paix voyez
vous nous avons connu une crise en
raison de l'excès d'exclusion nous
devons tirer les leçons de la crise
ivoirienne
aujourd'hui vu le comportement du rhdp
et du pouvoir en place
on a l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas tiré
les leçons de la crise ivoirienne la
crise ivoirienne est née de l'exclusion
il faut que l'exclusion c'est côte
d'ivoire ça veut dire que vous plaider
en faveur d'une amnistie cours l'ancien
chef de l'état ivoirien laurent gbagbo
charles blé goudé guillaume soro vous
dites que ça fait et les autres vous
dites que ça fait partie de la
réconciliation nationale pour la salle
et une bonne fois pour toutes
oui bien entendu voyez vous s'agissant
notamment de l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo et de charles blé goudé
ils ont été jugés par la cour pénale
internationale est acquitté à partir du
moment où nous les avons envoyés auprès
de la justice internationale et que
cette justice les a quittés ils doivent
entrer librement
en côte d'ivoire on ne peut pas juger
les mêmes personnes pour les mêmes faits
et ajouter d'autres créent ici en côte
d'ivoire pendant que eux sont à
l'extérieur il est jugé par contumace
ici alors que c'est nous mêmes qui les
avons envoyés avec ses vieux une
cohérence la justice c'est vrai que là
il ya une procédure encore judiciaire en
cours à la haye au niveau de la cpi mais
c'est 3 classique de la politique
ivoirienne sont aussi poursuivis par la
justice ivoirienne
le fait de dire on les amnisties s qui a
pas aussi le risque de voir l'impunité
triomphé dans votre pays est ce que
c'est réellement ce que souhaitent les
ivoiriens l'ensemble des ivoiriens
non ce que les allemands sont les
ouvriers souhait c'est une justice
équitable
on ne peut pas juger laurent gbagbo le
condamné pour des faits qui se sont
passés en côte d'ivoire que d'autres ont
également commis ici en côte d'ivoire
ils sont libres comme l'air en côte
d'ivoire ils roulent carrosse
aujourd'hui je vous parle du braquage de
la banque centrale
parmi les forces nouvelles qui composent
d'armes et de nombreux dans un individu
était évidemment acteurs à bouaké amant
et ont braqué la banque centrale il
sourit c'est le contribuable guarin
vous parlez dans cette affaire parce
qu'on va recontextualiser laurent gbagbo
il poursuivi dans cette affaire du
braquage de la bceao il ya vous dit
aussi qu'il ya des des membres des des
forces nouvelles qui était dirigé par
guillaume soro
oui tout à fait tout à fait et la banque
centrale a été braquée de bouaké donc il
y avait et des chefs de guerre qui se
sont servis à moitié pourquoi ne sont
ils pas poursuivis pourquoi ne sont ils
pas condamné voyez vous appartient
aujourd'hui au camp du rhdp
c'est ce que vous vous dites oui qui
sont qui sont dans leur mais aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont libres donc c'est une
réalité
pourquoi cela c'est dans ce sens qu'il
ya une justice des vainqueurs
et si nous voulons la paix en côte
d'ivoire
à partir du moment où cela ont été
amnistiés et que nous voulons sortir de
la crise de façon définitive
il faut véritablement connaître les
coupables à voir les condamnations qu'il
faut et décider librement de gracier
dany astier pour pour continuer ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il y est punie t mais
la justice doit s'appliquer pour tous
j'ai le mien et de cette justice il n'y
a pas de justice et là nous rentrons
dans un climat à chaque fois de
frustration qui créent l'instabilité
jean louis billon que peut apporter de
plus le pdci à la côte d'ivoire le pdci
d'henri konan bédié à une époque c'était
l'ivoirité le roger de l'étranger le
rejet de la candidature d'alassane
ouattara on s'en souvient a passé que
l'alliance au sein du rhdp a estompé par
la suite
à quoi ressemble le pdc y ait
aujourd'hui quelles sont ses ambitions
pour votre pays
le pdc à qui on a reproché l'ivoirité
est le même une pdci qui a soutenu
alassane ouattara par deux fois on l'a
mené à la présidence la république
donc s'il y a eu une faute par le passé
et cela est discutable
et bien cette photo avait été largement
réparée aujourd'hui le pdci n'est pas
acteur d'exclusion bien au contraire
voyez vous nous allons retrouver le
pouvoir gagner ces élections et il n'y
aura pas de chasse aux sorcières que les
partisans du rhdp se rassurent nous
n'allons pas les poursuivre on les
fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation frais des world
c'est important pour l'avenir et laisser
aux générations futures une côte
d'ivoire assainies de tous les
ingrédients d stabilité au sein d'un
front anti ouattara jean louis billon
là que c'est pas c'est pas que nous
soyons anti ouattara nous estimons que
il a fait deux mandats c'est bien il
doit aujourd'hui se retirer peut-être
présenter quelqu'un d'autre au niveau du
rhdp
voyez-vous la limitation des mandats et
pour le dynamisme d'un pays aujourd'hui
alassane ouattara est quelqu'un d'user
de fatigue et il a eu de mandat
difficile
simplement parce que la côte d'ivoire
sortait d'une longue crise et bien
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il a besoin de
repos réparateur et hériter merci
beaucoup à jean louis billon pour cette
grande interview je rappelle que vous
êtes le secrétaire exécutif de la
communication du pdci rda le parti de
l'ex président henri konan-bédié qui est
donc candidat pour la présidentielle du
31 octobre merci à vous merci et merci à
vous pour avoir suivi cette grande
interview que vous pouvez retrouver sur
nos réseaux sociaux en podcast sur notre
site internet arte france pointé des
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt
[Musique]
oui